this okay so my name is Krishna Kumar
and I basically work in this group at
microsoft that focuses on evangelism so
literally what I do is I get in front of
you know researchers and faculty
centrally around the u.s. and talk about
you know developer focused technologies
like you know windows azure cloud
computing is something I've been doing
for the last couple of years you know
ever since we introduced a sure so I'm
really excited to sort of talk about
that here today this talk actually is
going to be a slight modification from a
similar talk I gave at Microsoft
Research cloud futures last year but the
point I want to make here is I want to
make sure that it's customized for this
audience let's keep the super
interactive way I really don't have to
go through all the you know slide that
content that i have and yawns uploading
it right now so you have that content
already so i'm happy to deviate and talk
about other interesting things if if you
want before we get started just so I'm
sort of level setting at the right you
know level how many of you worked with
in some way shape or form with the cloud
before about towards three hands okay
and how many of you have looked at
Windows Azure two or three okay so i
think i think the content is at the
right level so what will really quickly
do over the next 60 minutes it's
basically just in one slide introduce
the cloud so we are all on the same page
in terms of what the cloud means because
you know it's one of those things that
you ask 20 people you get 40 different
opinions of what the cloud is right so
for purposes of windows azure and this
talk will define what the cloud is then
we'll really quickly look at you know
scenarios that make sense for the cloud
that you know are most commonly using
the cloud and then jump into windows
azure we'll look at the different
components of windows azure what I'm
going to the way I'm going to structure
structure it is i'm going to give you an
all-up view of everything that's in
windows azure right whatever is in the
platform and then we'll sort of drill
down and sort of get into the portal and
start programming just briefly with
Windows Azure I will
leave you with you know pointers and
resources to where you can find content
that will take you from where we left
off and sort of go from there so that's
going to be the overall flow so like I
said what is cloud computing this is
going to be my one slide definition so
the way we look at cloud computing is a
cloud is an offline you know location
agnostic set of infrastructure resources
whatever that is used to store data and
run applications and I think here is the
fundamental disconnect if you talk to a
lot of folks they'll be like you know
we've done cloud computing for years you
know if you store data someplace else
other than your infrastructure you're
using the cloud well technically yes but
in terms of computing we sort of
qualified as being able to run your
applications on the cloud right so what
a sure lets you do and this is basically
if this is all that as earnest as sure
lets you upload your data to the cloud
and Azure lets you upload your
applications to the cloud and that's the
fundamental premise of cloud computing
we will take your app and run it on the
same infrastructure that powers Bing and
hotmail and all of those properties and
you do not have to worry about a couple
of things things like scale right you
don't have to worry about provisioning
10 servers because you anticipate this
load or you don't have to worry about
you know provisioning more and more as
your audience base grows right all of
that is completely elastic we take care
of you know provisioning and deep
provisioning and allocating and D
allocating resources we also provide you
a utility billing model so literally you
only pay for what you use so think of
the whole cloud computing boiling down
to sort of the utility model of
computing where you pay only for what
you use and the usage and resource
allocation is elastic it's basically it
I basically said I mean that's basically
what the cloud is and there are certain
traditional kinds of applications that
make sense they do on the cloud
obviously not every kind of app is going
to be you know
the best case scenario for the cloud we
sort of broadly categorize you know this
quadrant I mean these four kinds of apps
any app that basically has an on/off
property you know an app runs for a
certain amount of time and then doesn't
for a certain amount of time or an app
that's basically doing some level of
bursting right I mean whether it's
predictable or unpredictable your your
peak usage characteristic is
significantly above your average usage
characteristic right in all of these
cases the cloud is perfect because the
elastic nature of the cloud will only
require this amount of compute resources
when the demands low but when the demand
spikes up the cloud will literally
expand it'll give you more
infrastructure to cover the spike in
your demand and then once the demand
goes away the resources get pulled back
and literally your cost curve very
closely follows this curve as well so
I'm not going to go into a whole lot of
detail as to why this is a good thing
because as you can imagine if the cloud
didn't do that you would have to
provision for peak right I mean you
would have to buy enough compute storage
resources to handle this level so for
all this other time when your service is
not running in peak capacity those
resources are getting wasted right so in
all of these cases the clouds amazing or
in an unpredictable case where you do
not know if your service is going to
require more resources the clouds great
as well now this is the traditional
slide we use with enterprises right
these are you know companies and and we
basically help them analyze that apps
and see if any of them fall in this
bucket to help them you know see if they
want to migrate that to the club for
this audience however I want to talk
about Big Data right i mean past couple
of days that's all we've been talking
vast amounts of data and i borrow these
slides actually from a faculty member at
university of washington but i think
this does a really good job of
explaining what the cloud is going to be
used for in the very present and coming
future so just basically all of science
and research for instance has followed
a progression if you will started off
with theory right before we had you know
experimentation capabilities before we
had all the cool devices you know you
just theorized and then later you
experiment and you basically confirm or
deny validate or invalidate theory then
sort of there was this whole phase of
observation at some point where
basically you observe data I mean you
would observe phenomena collect data and
then move to the sole computational
phase where all of that data that has
been collected now basically gets
processed and crunched and simulations
happen and modeling happens lately we've
been seeing this whole new field emerge
called e-science as everybody knows here
and one of the key fundamental defining
characteristic of e science is the vast
amounts of data that gets computed it
gets collected and computed through the
process just to give you a quick example
the amount of data that the current
generation telescope the Apache point
Sloan Digital Sky Survey telescope
Amasis is of the order of 80 terabytes
over a seven-year period right so over a
significant amount of time they've
amassed a significant amount of data and
to put this in perspective here's a
statistic that says that this telescope
collected more data in the first few
weeks then had been a mass in the entire
history of astronomy it just gives you a
scale for the data intensive kinds of
applications we are using today this new
telescope that's going to come up it's
basically down the road from me I live
in Chicago and this is an
urbana-champaign at the National Center
for supercomputing applications they're
coming up with a new large synoptic
survey telescope it's going to be
installed in Chile and that is going to
acquire a hundred and 40 terabytes of
data every five days right and just to
give you an idea these are some of the
infrastructural requirements that have
been set up to get this operational and
you'll be like why why do we need to
amass so much data and this sort of
gives you a sort of a perspective this
is the current
current generation telescope and you see
the resolution is pretty limited right I
mean you cannot make out you cannot
resolve certain smaller you know nebula
objects are in the sky whereas with the
newer model telescope that we are
anticipating come come up in 2016 we'll
be able to resolve far smaller objects
in a much better fashion so I was really
exciting I was actually just this was so
coincidental just like 10 days ago I was
speaking with one of the architects of
the LSST at NCSA and and he was talking
about the amount of data what they're
going to do with all that data and I was
talking about what plans do they have
for saving that data and how did they
plan to you know sort of process that
data and he was saying at this point
like today I mean if he had to go
operational he said that he'd basically
have to throw away most of the data
that's coming in just because they don't
have the infrastructure to handle it and
and even the cloud in this case would
not be a perfect scenario because
imagine how long it's going to take to
upload a hundred 40 terabytes of you
know data right so I mean it said some
of these interesting challenges that
make this feel so exciting so they're
basically coming up with sort of a
tiered solution where the incoming data
is going to be in a local warehouse and
is going to get processed and then
basically sent up to the sum of that
processed filter data is going to be
sent up to the cloud which will then be
further processed and so on and so forth
some other examples the Large Hadron
Collider you know generates again a huge
amount of data you know if and if you
think these are these multi-billion
dollar projects actually no I mean
closer to home some of these little
desktop sighs you know genome sequencer
produce vast quantities of data so the
point I'm trying to make us we live in a
world where science is driven by data
collection and sensors all over the
world and so basically being able to
analyze data at this scale is something
of the cloud Excel set right I mean
we've been talking about HBC and and all
of that is basically the cloud sort of
you will sort of build for that scenario
so with that I'm probably not going to
spend a whole amount of time on these
business statistics for you know Big
Data scenario except the poll probably
point out
maybe the last couple of points Walmart
everybody knows Walmart basically has
data warehouses databases totaling close
to like in the petabyte range and they
were stuff grown in the timeframe that
you know the slide that has been around
this sort of puts in perspective mankind
created 150 exabytes of data in 2005
this year of create 1,200 exabytes
interesting but the human mind sort of
has a limit in terms of how much you
know vast numbers it can absorb so to
put this again in perspective in the
last nine years or ten years actually
the basically the beginning of the 21st
century we have created more data than
has been a mass in the entire history of
humankind up until that point so imagine
you know beginning of mankind to the
year two thousand and two thousand 12
2010 basically we've created more data
in the past ten years and and we're
going to exceed that rare that that
amount of data in the next three to four
years right so where's all this kapade
are going to go we really don't have any
storage space to store these and if you
if you look at some of these statistics
our ability to store data has far far
fallen behind our ability to create data
or the rate at which we're creating data
so that the future it seems is in the is
looking as the word garage is basically
to real-time analysis of data and then
the cloud really is the way to go some
quick statistics from Facebook and
Google these are dated slightly dated
but just to give you an what some of
these properties on the internet will
apply as well so all of these different
kinds of applications will be benefited
by the cloud so having said that let's
sort of do sort of a slightly deeper
dive into cloud computing and look at
the different versions of the cloud if
you were right if you look at any you
know literature on the cloud or speak to
anybody from the cloud perspective they
basically point two three sort of
segregations if you will off the
services that cloud can provide
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service
right as the name suggests
with infrastructure-as-a-service what
happens is a cloud provider and Amazon's
probably the best example for the
scenario a cloud provider will provide
you raw infrastructure right so you'll
get literally a box in the sky you'll
get an IP address or I mean you'll get
one or how many of our machines you
request on the cloud so you'll get an IP
address that will connect to that
machine and that machine belongs to you
you can install whatever operating
system you want on it you can install
whatever tool said you want on it and
and run any application that you want on
it the flip side of the coin is that the
administration of that machine is also
your responsibility right if an update
needs to be patched I mean if an update
needs to be applied or if a machine
needs to be patched if machine needs to
be rebooted whatever all of that
maintenance is also on you the next
level is platform-as-a-service where the
vendor doesn't provide you with a raw
box what the vendor does is sort of
installs a bunch of lower-level software
on the machine like the operating system
like the you know the runtime for
whatever platform that you're interested
in it could be java.net so they install
a bunch of runtimes and expose that
machine using a set of AP ice so you
basically can upload an application you
can basically build an application and
applauded and the platform as a service
model will take that app and run it
seamlessly across multiple machines
without giving you the headache of
worrying about each and every single
machine and you know patching and
upgrading each and every single machine
and finally software-as-a-service
scenario basically it's just a model
where you are all you're exposed to have
sort of a web front-end and then
everything else happens you know behind
the scenes in the cloud the cloud model
any questions so far okay so what we're
going to explore now is windows azure
and i'm going to show you basically how
windows azure allows is mostly a
platform as a service windows azure is
sort of a classic platform-as-a-service
scenario but you're able to
the elements of infrastructure as a
service as well in our offering so this
basically just sort of in a visual
fashion represents what we just talked
about in infrastructure as a service the
vendor buddies about the actual hardware
they'll they'll you know set up the
machine set up the networking but
anything OS and above is your problem
platform-as-a-service all of the
infrastructural software is handled by
the vendor you just basically get a
unified platform dotnet platform or
consistent set of AP is and all you do
is just write an application and upload
it to the cloud the verses software as a
service you basically don't have any
level of control on what the cloud does
or exposes you can basically consume the
cloud using a web browser and
applications like office life or sales
force or an example of software as a
service I'm going to jump through this
again recaps most of it the only thing I
wanted to mention is most enterprises
seem to think that there's the world
with the cloud or there's a world
without the cloud the point I want to
try and make is there is this very
robust hybrid cloud scenario right and I
think this is where the future is headed
in terms of cloud computing where people
with existing investments in hardware
locally will continue to use those
resources and then when the demand far
exceeds the supply that they can locally
provide the application will be smart
enough to burst into the cloud and run
on the cloud as well so an application
is is aware self-aware enough that if it
feels that it's constrained by the local
resources it will basically spin up new
instances in the cloud and start running
on the cloud as well and when the
traffic goes away the instances in the
cloud will be spun down and the
application will come back to running
purely on premise it's kind of the
future if you look at some of the AP is
that we're building around some of the
cloud api's and on-premise api's you
basically see them converge so our
ultimate goal is to be
able to write you or help you write an
application once that app runs on
premise on the cloud or both places
right straddle both infrastructures so
it's kind of the future so it's kind of
obvious I mean the way computing works
on the cloud is by scaling out right so
you take a nap and you have it run on
more and more machines as your
requirements for capacity go up you
don't really scale up you kind of scale
out and the way we do that is basically
by just running data or running your
applications and massive data centers so
the cloud if you will is just basically
a massive data center right operated by
whichever vendor at this point I
basically have a quick video that I
normally show but in the interest of
time given that i'm already add about
half I'm probably just going to point
you I think the slide deck has links to
it but basically what I would normally
show here is the way that the current
generation of data centers is being
built and the whole container based
approach to data centers which makes us
you know very agile in creating new data
centers and adding capacity to existing
data centers but I'm going to sort of
jump through that because the links are
in the slide deck anyway okay so I'm
going to basically jump to a shore now
or sort of talk through the
transformation to Azure I just said that
when you program an application for the
cloud you're literally writing a program
for the data center and programming
massively parallel massively distributed
applications is a huge problem right it
doesn't the complexity doesn't scale
linearly it's sort of an exponential
complexity increment when you talk about
massive applications so the goal of
Asher was basically to take all of
Microsoft experience and building
massive distributed properties all of
these and sort of come up with what we
call an operating system for the cloud
so what Asher does is acts as an OS for
the cloud where it basically
what is about all of the complexities as
it relates to spanning a nap across
multiple machines some of the more you
know mundane issues like what happens if
a machine dice when an application is
running on it or what happens if a patch
needs to be applied when your app is
running on it so we take care of all of
that and all you have to do is basically
worry about writing the actual code that
you want executing so if how to define
Windows Azure in one phrase I would call
it an operating system for the cloud we
basically take away all of the
complexity of the cloud and expose one
unified API that you used to write an
application and once that app has been
written that app can run on one machine
or a thousand machines concurrently
without having to be you know modified
or specifically having to worry about
the parallel parallelism what's
happening there so there are three broad
components that Windows Azure the
operating system or the cloud exposes
obviously the first two are pretty
obvious it exposes sort of a compute
mechanism for you to be able to upload
apps and run on the cloud it exposes a
storage mechanism or you to be able to
store data and from an infrastructural
administration point of view it exposes
what's called a sure connect or this
perspective of being on a virtual
network on your virtual network so what
this allows you to do is it allows you
to basically take that cluster of
computers or machines that are running
in the cloud and have them look as
though their extensions of your local
network so they'll basically map to the
IP addressing scheme of your local
namespace of your local IP region and
the software in the middle will
basically take all the access that's
happening locally and then convert them
map those into the actual IP addresses
in the in the cloud so this virtual
network is basically useful if you've
got you know policies that you apply
locally the machines and you want them
extended
into the cloud as well so that's
basically Windows Azure windows azure
forms the backbone of the broader Azure
platform right so there's two components
actually there's the windows azure the
operating system for the cloud and
there's the windows azure platform that
basically encompasses all of the online
developer properties that microsoft owns
which includes windows azure which
includes sequel azure because you know
windows azure does not have a relational
data storage mechanism so sequel Azure
comes in its support off sequel server
for the cloud and it basically runs on
the cloud and and the same mechanism
holds true it basically is in the cloud
its elastic it's scalable pay for what
you use and all of that but relational
database in the cloud as your app fabric
is a set of services that help you
connect applications running on premise
to applications running in the cloud so
this is interesting because a few things
come into play fundamentally two things
come into play when you're talking about
apps that need to run on the cloud that
need however to communicate back home to
the machines within the infrastructure
the two things are access how can a
server is running in the cloud sort of
navigate your local firewall policies
and all of that and make an inbound
connection into the end of price and
number two authentication and
authorization right if you have an
authentication policy in house how do
you make sure that the service that's
living in the cloud follows the same
with mitigation policy and all of that
so access control and sort of the
service plus if you will which connects
the services running in the cloud to
data and services running on premise
those two are the fundamental components
of azure appfabric and as you saw
yesterday we sort of support a
marketplace that also runs on azure that
you can use to consume data hosted by
other folks or expose your own data for
free or for a fee so that's sort of the
overall ecosystem of the windows azure
platform on top of which you can build
your own applications and post your own
data
so I'm just going to drill one level
deeper into each of these three major
components and then we'll look at an
actual live implementation of a nap and
throw it up onto the under the cloud so
Windows Azure we saw basically expose
this compute and storage the key brains
if you will of Windows Azure it's what's
called a fabric controller so this is
basically an infrastructure layer
software that runs on the cloud that
manages the health of all of the
applications and all of the hardware
that the applications run on top of so
if it detects that you know your
application has crashed for whatever
reason or if it detects that one of
these nodes on with your app is running
has you know has you know tired or
whatever it'll make sure that a new
instance of the app is brought up and
you know it's brought online and added
to the pool of running applications so
when you sort of program some of these
cloud cloud aware apps if you sort of
keep in mind to not store state locally
and things like that because you should
always keep in mind that this app could
die at any point in time do a sort of a
non graceful exit exit and a new
instance a brand new instance will be
spawned at any point of time and so
basically that's the only thing to keep
in mind as you sort of transition from
buildings local on premise apps to cloud
apps so basically not saving any local
state saving state on in a durable
storage like the azure storage and and
stuff like that but fabric controller
handles all of that it handles load
balancing it handles you know hardware
failure software failures all of that I
said I mentioned connect already connect
basically allows you to make these
infrastructure and the cloud look like
an extension of your local
infrastructure along the same IP range
looking at compute briefly so I said
computer allows you to upload your own
applications into the cloud and run them
on the cloud there are two broad
segmentations if you were off the kinds
of compute possible on the
at the at the base layer it's all the
same it's just basically some code that
runs on the cloud but the way we
distinguish between these is by way of
whether your role your application
running in the cloud does it have a web
server in front of it or does it not
have a web server in front of it so if
you build a web application or website
or web service that needs to be
contacted by the outside world you will
code it as a web role basically what
will happen is that image the virtual
machine on mature code will be running
will have I is internet information
services in our web server installed if
the code that you're running does not
need to be contacted by the external
world then you would code it as a worker
role so if all you're doing is computing
pi to 10 million digits or something and
the results will just get sent back
through as your storage or whatever you
would code it as a worker role and
everything is load balanced and we
talked about talked about the fabric
that'll make sure that everything you
know all the integrity of all the
applications is is maintained so just a
few highlights I'm going to jump through
though just really briefly look at
storage we expose three kinds of storage
one is blobs and this is probably the
storage mechanism you'll use most
commonly because this sort of closely
mirrors local storage or the hard drive
on your machine right so anything you
can store on your hard drive did you
know is a file and any file can be
stored in a blob this could be text
files this could be finally data you
know movies and audio or sub files
whatever and be stored in a blob it's
just basically a binary large object
that's all it is any data that can be
tabular Lee structured right sort of
Excel level data if you will rows and
columns will get represented as a table
and even though the name is table it's
not a relational table it's just
basically if you will unstructured rows
and column data basically it it doesn't
enforce a schema so you should not
basically expect the table to
automatically in for scheme I does yeah
question
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
table on the table it's restricted to
dimensions so just you know x and y yeah
although I would think that it might be
possible to extrapolate you know using
your own code so if you maybe have two
tables that index each other and sort of
extended the third dimension that might
be an option but out of the box a table
as your tables 2d and finally queues
which is basically as the name suggests
just a quick data structure to pass
messages back and forth but sort of a
first-in-first-out mechanism question
yes this question was if the documents
basically get yeah if the documents
basically gets stored in the blob as
binary data how do you apply such
criteria right so there are interesting
ways to do it basically the azure
storage mechanism will not extract
metadata and make it accessible or
searchable by default so if that
searchability is is paramount if it's
important what we basically recommend is
sort of use blobs to store data but then
use as your tables to sort of maintain a
separate metadata table so a sort of a
link to the blob and then some of the
keywords or tags if you will that
represent the blog and that could either
be manual or that could be automatic
where some worker process comes and
looks at the contents of the blob and
extracts a bunch of meaningful
information and stores it in the table
and then the search would actually
happen on the table and then get
dereference back to the blob I don't
know if that made sense so that means
external a parameter called as a
processing or a business layer to
extract metadata before storing the
information yes at the way it stands now
yes the blob does not expose a
structured so it doesn't do something
like Windows Explorer does if you will
wear it exposes you know all the files
that it has and all of the metadata
about the files and all of that it
doesn't by default do that you can you
can with each blob image though you can
save some metadata I mean I think if I'm
not mistaken it's about 8 kilobytes or
twenty four kilobytes it's a small
amount but you can source some metadata
but it's your responsibility to store
the metadata in with the blob so as your
storage would not look into the content
of your blob and extract meaningful
information and store that as metadata
is what I'm trying to say and what are
the size limitations like can feel the
regular OS you have size limitation that
you can store like four gig or something
like that right but what is about the
block because you said it's very small
so how does it know the metadata field
is relatively small the blob I'm not
sure that it has a size limitation at
all ed sorry no it's it's definitely not
so that I know for sure it's not
constrained by the NTFS size limit
limitation because basically what's
happening is behind the scenes it's got
a storage storage array that basically
sort of breaks the blob if you will
across multiple hard drives if need be
so it's not constrained by the
traditional size limitations of ntfs or
fat so that's a good point to check out
a simple web search should give you that
information I know that a queue for
instance has a size limitation of 8
kilobytes so what Q message can only be
8 kilobytes a table also has a size
limitation not in the size of the
overall table but in the size of each
field like each column data in the table
can only be certain kilobytes the blob
as far as I know does not
have a size limitation it can grow to
the size of your storage count
worst-case scenario so the storage
account though has a size limitation of
a few hundred terabytes or so but again
a simple search should reveal that
number question sir if Microsoft were to
develop an overlay that would facilitate
storage of heterogeneous data with some
control over metadata annotation that
would actually be a big win for the
scientific community and now there's a
lot of people that have lots of data
they don't all relate to each other but
they want to get it stored somewhere and
they want to be able to search over it
so if you can come up with tools for
that absolutely I think I think it's
good feedback Yan is there a way to
collect this feedback and pass it on to
the party he didn't write as mg I'm
gonna set up some kind of mechanism for
you guys yeah but I will remember to
send this gentleman's feedbacks ready
but it totally does make sense i mean if
there's a there's a sort of a simplified
mechanism where i can upload something
and have metadata associated with it
that's easily searchable that gets
grouped up and easily searchable yeah
absolutely yeah I mean you'll find there
are certain third-party applications if
I can show you one so there's this
application called cloud storage studio
and I could basically so what this is
doing now is it basically is giving me a
view of what's in my Asher blob storage
so I have these folders if you will we
call them containers and sort of folders
so this basically leads containers for
those of you in the back it's kind of
hard to read this is containers and
these are the separate containers that I
have with in my storage account and I
have the storage account called said
docks which has a few document a few
word files and PowerPoint files so this
is some metadata that
is exposed automatically and this sort
of gives me a sort of a Windows Explorer
look and feel and I can basically go in
and let's see view edit bra blob
properties and I can come in and insert
some metadata a metadata is just
basically a name value combination so I
could do something like you know topic
or something and say a sure and say
insert metadata and now this is
basically part of this blobs metadata so
blob storage absolutely does support
metadata like I said but then once I
save it and close it now how this
becomes searchable is an interesting
point I think back to your point I think
it's very valid feedback in terms of
exploring options of making these
searchable just as you would a local
file system so again okay any other
questions so far yeah cannot be done in
a cloud is 0 then it can be done in
regular oh yes that we have yeah so the
question yeah everybody heard the
question if I did this talk about 8
months back I would have told you that
in Azure you do not run as administrator
right so anything that requires admin
privileges you couldn't have done but in
the PDC that just happened last year the
professional developers conference we
added that feature right so when your
application runs in Azure it runs as
admin so you can basically do everything
on your app can do anything on the cloud
that an admin code on the local box I
would say technically there is really
nothing you cannot do except there are
certain things we would recommend you do
not do so things like for instance not
save anything to your local drive right
not save anything to your local C Drive
or whatever the drive that's exposed in
the cloud just because like I said if
that machine goes down for whatever
reasons a new machine will get spawned
with with an instance of your
application and that C Drive content
would not have
being replicated right so the temporal
data that's in the machine that hasn't
been committed to Azure storage would be
lost forever so we recommend not saving
local state we recommend not caching
something locally unless that data can
be reconstituted on the fly by some
other instance stuff like that but
literally it's a box in the sky I'll
actually show you can actually even
remote desktop to one of those and and
you know just do whatever you want
configure it anywhere you want we even
allow you to build your own custom image
your own virtual machine image based off
of windows server 2008 and upload it to
the cloud and we will take that v HD and
run it for you right so if your
application needs I don't know certain
dll's if it needs a few specialized
applications already installed in the
image we will absolutely have facilities
to let you do it probably the only thing
that you won't see from us in Azure for
for probably a long long time is the
ability to run a non-windows operating
system so we do not intend that means
for the foreseeable future hosting an on
Windows OS for instance you won't see us
host you know sort of a Linux variant on
the cloud right which you can with
amazon today but not with windows azure
because it's going to be because most of
our infrastructure all of our
infrastructure including the hypervisors
and the virtualization infrastructure is
all optimized for windows server 2008
and that basically gives you a huge
advantage because when you run on the
cloud even though you're running in a
virtualized environment your performance
envelope is at the 90th percentile of
what it be if you ran on bare metal
hardware right and that 90th percentile
performance is only achieved because of
the hyper optimized hypervisor that runs
on the cloud and so if we changed the OS
or if we changed even the hydra or the
hardware configuration we would
basically have to read tweak the
hypervisor or each of those that's why I
basically say even though you can upload
your own hard drive images v HD s they
need to be based off of Windows Server
2008 r2 just because hypervisor is
optimized
environment question yeah but if you
create a particular instance if you
request about the configuration for as
your instance right is it consistent
like if you had to change later on based
on a performance issues or something of
that does it automatically reconfigure
the RAM and disk or is it something that
you have to request a new instance
altogether right so the there are two
parts to that we can add and remove
instances on the fly so if you basically
upload an application and say I want 20
instances of this app to run that number
20 can be up or lowered on the fly so
you can basically come in and say I now
I need 30 and will spin up 10 more and
now you can say I want that number back
to 10 and we'll take down 20 right but
if you want the actual instance the vm
the hardware configuration of the vm to
change for instance so now instead of
saying i instead of quad-core machines
host me on an eight-core machine that
would basically require taking down the
application and bringing up a new
instance of you know the virtual image
on an eight-core machine and loading
your application onto that so that would
mean bringing down the application and
then reinitiating it on a different kind
of run time environment did that make
sense so instances can be increased and
lowered at runtime without bringing down
the service so instead of five instances
i can give you 10 or take down five or
whatever but the type of instance on
which you're running when i say the type
of instance I mean the size of the
instance where you're running on a
single core machine single core VM image
dual core quad core eight core so we
offer four sizes right small medium
large extra large now we offer extra
small but basically small medium large
extra large the only differences between
the size of the machine on which you're
running a small machine has one core and
768 megabytes of RAM a medium machine
has two cores and 1.5 gigs
and as you can imagine the next size up
as large four cores and and three gig
and the extra-large has eight cores and
six gigs of RAM right so if you change
that instant size we will have to bring
down your app and redeploy it just
because the the image on which your app
is running has to be changed
transplanted over to a different piece
of hardware literally it's so that's
basically what happens there okay so I
see if I I have about 15 minutes and so
what I'm going to do is basically the
next two minutes I'm going to try and
get through the slides and show you the
demo because I really want us to have an
experience of the actual porter so I'm
not going to we looked at all of these
key thing I want to mention is all of
azure storage is exposed to be at rest
and we looked at web services and rest
yesterday which basically means that you
could store you could store your data in
Azure storage and still access that from
any platform in the world now these
could be platforms on premise these
could be windows platforms non windows
platforms so basically the point in
printer maker is if you store data and
azure storage it's not just accessible
from a sure it's accessible from any
node anywhere that can talk HTTP
basically that's it so I'm going to jump
through tables basically I said you know
tables are rows and columns there we
call them entity and entities and
records and queues are the primary
mechanism to communicate between roles
so basically a queue is sort of like a
set of first and first start messaging
mechanism and we recommend that you have
your components communicate to each
other through a queue just because like
I said I mean these these are very
temporary I mean these could die at any
time so you don't want your web roll
initiating a direct connection to your
work a roll just because what if the
worker dies and then now your web role
is just waiting sort of an infinite
waiting fish so use the queue and even
if this worker dies then
new worker that gets pond will know to
consume from this queue and keep
processing the message and we have
semantics in place that if a message
from the queue is pulled and not
explicitly deleted then the message will
reappear back in 30 seconds so even if a
worker role pulls a message and starts
processing it but sort of crashes in
between that that queue item that
message will not get lost because it
will show up again in 30 seconds because
it has not been explicitly deleted so
sequel Azure really quick exposes the
basic database engine exposes the
reporting and the data sync
functionality basically which means that
allows you to store relational data it
allows you to run reports on relational
data allows you to sync between multiple
instances of sequel as your or between a
sequel server and a sequel as your
instance so if one instance has an
update happen on it all the other
instances will get you know the change
is propagated to them it Iran if you use
data same the key thing to keep in mind
is the the current size of a sequel
Azure instance can grow up to 50
gigabytes if your application has a
database larger than 50 gig you have to
shard them into multiple databases and
the reason it's it's truncated at 50
gigas to make sure that it scales on the
web right if the sizes get too large and
if you basically have to maintain data
integrity it at one point becomes
relatively expensive to make sure that
that the update replicates across all
the you know related tables in a timely
fashion and so basically we sort of
truncated at 50 gigabytes and you
basically manually shard your instance
across instances finally a fabric like I
said mentioned the you know offers a
service bus offers access control and
offers a distributed cache and the
service bus basically we jump in here
it literally does this if one service
and you know some organization or
on-premise wants to talk to another
service in a different org or on the
cloud or whatever and if these are
separated by firewalls and network
boundaries that did not allow inbound
connections the service bus access sort
of a relay in between if you will that
allow applications to talk via that
relay so the way it works really simply
is the service bus initiates the
applications within those orgs will
initiate a request to the service bus
and the firewall since it's seeing that
it's an outbound request will allow that
request to go through the service bus
then what's going to do is it's going to
take this connection and hold it open
it's going to keep the connection open
and then any data that needs to be
transferred back and forth is done via
the service bus it'll basically take
data from here and transfer it here and
vice versa if it detects however that
the the boundaries will allow for direct
connection it'll make the direct
connection happen and and back off but
otherwise it's going to just basically
act as a router or a relay to allow
communication to happen so that was
basically the all up look the so we
looked at Windows Azure we lived at the
azure appfabric with AB that's equalizer
and the last point I want to make is
basically this is not a pure Microsoft
platform player right i mean everything
like i said exposes rest everything
exposes o data and as we've seen over
the last couple of days all of these
technologies are interoperable which
basically means you can target as you're
using a bunch of different technologies
a bunch of different languages or a
bunch of different ide environments and
so on and so forth so it's a very
completely interoperable platform to
play with so with that what I'm going to
do is sort of in the next 10 minutes
sort of give you a very abbreviated
experience of programming a Windows
Azure application so what I'm going to
do is fire up visual studio and I'm
going to run this as illustrator just
because of a couple of components
required
to be admin so when visual studio comes
up I already have the azure SDK
installed what I would do then is
basically just to new project as usual
and in the in the dialogue that comes up
there's there's going to be once you
install the azure SDK you will have this
cloud tab and then you hit cloud you
give it a project name let's just say
hello MSR and say okay and at this point
it's basically going to throw up another
dialog and ask you okay I see you're
trying to build a Windows Azure computer
application what kind of roles do you
want do you want web roles you want
worker roles you know what kind of roles
and you'll see you have a traditional
asp.net web ro SP dot net MVC web raw a
web service web raw or you have a worker
raw but if you wanted to build something
SE non microsoft technologies like
asp.net if you want to disable the PHP
web raw you can just just choose the
generic CGI web row and any language
that supports fast CGI Python Perl any
of those languages support procedure i
will be a programmable using this
mechanism I'm just going to for now
choosing a regular asp.net web raw it's
called web roll 1 i'm okay with that
name i'm going to choose okay in fact
you know what let me throw in a worker
role as well so i got a weblog a worker
role in this project i'm going to say
okay and so it's going to go off and and
build the default asp.net web role
application it's going to build the
default work a role application and come
back in a second
okay so basically in the solution
structure we just minimize these for a
second what you'll see is you have your
web roles you have your worker role and
this is the all up cloud solution and
basically you see that it basically has
these two roles and it's also got some
configuration files let me increase the
font on this and this is the config file
that you can actually modify to say how
many instances do you want or how many
you know or if you need any specific
settings in your roles because remember
again what's happening is these
applications when you deploy to the
cloud will go and get installed on the
vm and start running right obviously you
don't have any direct control of the vm
so it's almost as though you're handing
this app off your admin and saying hey
admin or this app to run I need you know
the following to happen I need the
machine can figure it this way I need
the support open because i'm going to
talk on that port maybe i need you know
diagnostics enabled and all of that so
this is literally your instruction set
your virtual admin which in this case is
the the azure you know infrastructure
layer so you basically say i need this
many instances i need you know these
ports open all of that in this case we
aren't opening any ports but literally
you can configure all of those things
and what's going to happen is the azure
fabric controller will will get this
file first when it sets up the vm it's
going to set it up with all of these
requirements and then following that you
can actually go in and actually just you
know build your application so basically
here's my default aspx page which is
basically my default asp page and i
would just go and build this exactly
like what a regular asp.net application
and this is really the best part of
azure development using visual studio is
basically you take all of your existing
know how in building existing Microsoft
Technology applications like in a web
apps and services and sort of poured
them to the cloud so the experience is
exactly the same I can come in I can use
the tool box the drag-and-drop
design support designer support maybe I
can throw in let's just do a regular
hello world application so I'm going to
throw in a textbox I'm going to throw in
a button next to it I'm going to throw
in a label that's going to display the
hello world message so having brought
these three things let me bring the
label to the next line and I can just
coat it up I basically go in I get full
visual studio support I can basically
say a label let me increase the font
label 1 dot label 1 dot txt a template
control equals hello + was that
textbox1.text for now in the interest of
time let's just do this the key thing I
want to also point out now is at this
point I can just hit you no f5 or head
start debugging and here's what's going
to happen now it's very cool obviously
you don't want to build your application
and throw it up on the cloud see if it
runs bring it back and keep you know
modifying it that's it's sort of the
whole deploy to the cloud takes about 10
minutes right and so if you had to do
that every single time it's kind of
detrimental to your productivity so what
we have done is sort of along with the
SDK we have shipped a high-fidelity high
fidelity so I don't know what that sign
means are you trying to say it's I've
got only 10 minutes or oh sorry okay now
I've got five minutes okay cool um oh
okay gotcha sorry so we've shipped a
very high fidelity simulation of the
cloud on your local machine so what
that's going to let you do is I thought
I hit f5 okay it says running the
deployment and I don't see the
deployment open up though which is
interesting
that shift if I have to stop okay while
it stops so yeah it's still running it
for some weird reason let me go in and
look at the UI so this is basically the
UI for the local cloud environment if
you will it's going to come up hopefully
in a second so it's still doing
something else which is weird oh here
this so this is an MMC snappin that
basically shows me any local instances
that are running and right now this
hello ms our application if you can see
here is running one liberal and one
worker roll and here it comes up finally
my web page it should have that same UI
that we built up and you can see here
that I'm running one instance of my web
role and one instance of my worker role
which right now is in doing anything
questions are so I'm going to vote so
I'm a developer and I'm writing code if
I wanted to get feedback on that could I
package this up and then another user on
another computer run this emulator and
just run this application absolutely yes
so as long as they have the azure SDK
you can send them the the compile the cs
package file we call it the cs PKG cloud
service package right you send them that
and they'll be able to run it on their
local box so they won't need to install
is in any other prereqs I is is a prereq
for azure sdk to be in spain so they
would need IAS just because this Web
role is actually running on your local
instance of I is okay so they would need
is but then they wouldn't need anything
beyond the runtime the azure runtime on
their machine that's basically yeah all
they need so this gives you a very you
know sort of a fast turnaround in terms
of you know sort of the bill debug build
debug cycle and you can see all of the
you know spew debug view from your
applications that are running the next
step is you would take this and you
would upload it to the cloud right so
the way you would do that is you would
go to Windows
dodge or calm and that should bring out
the windows azure portal which i think i
already have opened or ok it's opening
here so which is relatively slow ok here
this so this is the windows azure portal
and it basically gives you a sort of a
control grid off you know how many
compute nodes you have running or
compute instances you're running how
many storage accountants or computer
accounts you have and all of that so I
would go in here and let's just see what
the provisioning a new computer account
looks like right so a computer count is
basically what's called a hosted service
we call it a hosted service a storage
account is what we call a storage
service or a storage account a user
management allows you to go in and and
you know customize you know your billing
information all of that VM images you
know how I said you can create your own
virtual image which will hard drive and
upload it you would do it through here
CDN is our content distribution network
so all of our storage accounts are
backed by a content distribution network
so you can basically activate this do
allow faster access to all the data that
you've got in the storage so let's just
quickly run through what creating a new
host account would look like you just
basically provide a name for your
service i'm going to say hello ms are
and see if it's available and you
provide a URL for accessing your service
i'm going to again say hello ms r is
available ok the requested name has
already been taken how about a hell of a
mess are one ok that's fine now you
choose a region where you want your
application or service to be deployed
and we have six locations around the
world north and south central us
northern south north and west europe and
eastern south asia or you can choose
anywhere asia anywhere you are up in
anywhere us so you can basically choose
i'm going to choose let's say north
central us this is the data center just
north of chicago and i'm going to say
choose this and i can come in and grab
the cloud service package file that i
talked about so right here I can
flick this hello ms our project click on
publish you want to start debugging yes
and when I say publish it'll create let
me show you what it does it'll basically
compile the whole application and create
a cloud service package file and the
cloud service configuration file habla
started and it's going to do that in a
second so i would basically just take
those two files and upload it to the
cloud and my application is going to be
running on the cloud so i knew that i
might run out at a time so here's the
two files that the visual studio
generated for me and i would just point
those two files here and say okay and
that's it but in the interest of time I
already had uploaded an instance already
so here is that instance i called it
simple demo and i can go in and click
this URL simple demo apt or clarinet and
it's that same app so i could basically
say MSR hit the button and basically say
MSR oh i didn't have it say hello but
whatever and in my last 30 seconds what
i'm going to show you really quick so
again this app is running from the cloud
if you look at the URL it's simple demo
to cloudapp net and cloudapp net is the
domain name that microsoft windows azure
uses for hosting a juror programs the
final thing i want to show you is I told
you how I will show you how as your
exposes the infrastructure as a service
functionality to you and the way you can
do that is basically in this dashboard
you can see that in my simple demo app
demo application I have this one role
and I have this one instance now again
what like I said each instance runs in
its own vm its own Windows Server
instance right I am now able to connect
to it so I can basically say connect and
what it's going to do is it's going to
open an rdp file at a more desktop file
but I can click on opens and oh because
the the firewall is blocking it so let
me do this really quick I'm going to
disconnect from the Microsoft Network
oh no I'm connected to the employee
network let me connect to my Wi-Fi
hotspot I think it's connecting there it
is dial so I'm now going out of the
Microsoft network connecting to my
hotspot that's now connected now let me
hit connect on this okay the RDP file
comes up I head open and now it asked me
it comes up and when I set up this image
I had activated remote desktop
functionality and had given it a
username and password i just use that
same username and password and now if
you look word and what's going to happen
now is it's going to let me connect to
this machine in the cloud and I say yes
connect me there and so hopefully in a
few seconds this is my machine in the
cloud on which the hello you know simple
demo service the hello world service is
now running just basically i'll show you
a cue a few really cool things if you do
wait we're in command let's do a quick
ipconfig it shows you some really cool
things so the code name for azure before
it became measure with red dog so you
see there basically using the same you
know a top-level domain red dog that my
croissant this is our IP so you can
actually no this is your machine so you
can basically come and install any app
you want again like I said you are admin
on this box so you can basically
customize this box as you see fit you
can go into IAS and see that app actual
application running so this is literally
the machine in the cloud and the windows
azure or Chicago data center it's
hosting our hello world application so
with that that's all I have way more
things I want to talk about with you but
I'm sadly out of time do we have time
for maybe a couple of questions or
maybe you want to what are the questions
that you have one appears to show one of
the things this is he actually inspired
by your work are you a support oh I want
to show their work oh very cool yeah
okay so how much is maybe yeah quick
question it was a question yes sir for
students that are using visual studio in
developing cloud projects after they
test them on the local environment are
you going to offer any free capability
to deploy to the cloud so we're still
trying to come up with one unified
offering for students all over the US
we're still working on that but for you
know selected faculty that you know we
have established relationships with we
actually come up with some way to do it
too like today we have an offering that
will allow any student to go in and get
a 30 day as your pass which will allow
them to get access on Azure without
having to enter credit card or
registration information and stuff like
that so I will I will follow with Yun
and send the instructions on how
students can actually activate the 30
day pass and if you can / it out yeah
okay all right thank you very much i
have a few parts using here thank you my
pleasure